well Happy Easter everybody I hope you
had a good one and I'll say that my
Easter was very good great day overall
kind of ruined though I got to be honest
at the very end because I was waiting
all day for my kids to go to bed so that
I could go and raid their Easter baskets
and take you know whatever candy I
wanted such as my tradition but when
they finally went to bed and I you know
I went to go carry out the the the
operation I discovered that they'd eaten
all the good jelly beans like all the
red and orange ones were gone I mean
they they somehow picked through all of
them left me only the purple and green
ones and it was pretty outrageous
I mean everything I do for this family
and Here I am left with purple and green
jelly beans and so there's a new new
rule that I'm in stating in this
household which is you will save the
good jelly beans for dead okay that's
just that's just the way it's gonna be
now I know you might say well you know
why don't you just go out and buy your
own bag of jelly beans you could buy as
much jelly beans as you want well and
sometimes it does seem like we forget
that we can do that as adults like it's
it's you get really excited about
stealing your kids Halloween candy going
through their but their bag when they're
when they're asleep and you know trying
to find the little small snicker bars
and stuff and it's almost like you
forget that well you could just go to
the grocery store and buy all the
snicker bars you want you're a grown-up
that's you can do that now but what you
don't understand is that unless you're a
parent it's hard to understand this but
is stealing stolen candy from your kids
tastes so much better than regular candy
there's something about the act of
stealing it that makes it just sweeter
it's like a flavor enhancement I can't
really explain it but that's just how it
is
so now unfortunately no flavor
enhancement could make purple jelly
beans okay and so nothing will ever
balance out this injustice that I have
suffered but I won't harp on that too
much before we get to the big news of
the day I want to tell you about
speaking of food I want to tell you
about wise foods you know we may not
like to think about it but disasters
happen at anytime hurricanes tornados
earthquakes floods wildfires power
outages even even something like losing
your job could be now it might not be a
natural disaster but that is a it could
be a
a disastrous effect on yourself and your
income and your life and your family and
it can put you in a spot where finding
your next meal might be kind of
difficult so here's the good news
wise company freeze-dried food is easy
repair and it can be stored for up to 25
years ok now I can tell you that being
prepared that way knowing you have the
provisions that you might need it leads
to among other things peace of mind
which is which is really priceless so
wise company takes an innovative
approach in providing dependable simple
and affordable freeze-dried food for
emergency preparedness and outdoor use
this is what really matters
wise company meals are designed to
protect your most valuable asset which
of course is your family when government
resources are strained it can be days if
not weeks before you get to find fresh
food and water and you can't rely on
someone else can't rely on the
government you can't rely on you know a
friendly neighbor coming by and bailing
you out self-sufficiency that's jen not
just the smart way it's the American Way
so this week my listeners can get any
wise emergency or outdoor food product
at an extra 25% off the lowest marked
price at wise food storage comm when
entering Walsh wal SH at checkout or by
calling eight five five four seven five
three eight nine plus shipping is free
so Wise has a 90 day no questions asked
return policy there's no risk in taking
the initiative to get yourself and your
family prepared today that's wise food
storage comm promo code Walsh to get any
wise emergency or outdoor food products
at an extra 25% off and free shipping
wise food storage comm promo code Walsh
all right tragedy in Sri Lanka on Easter
as 290 people have been murdered in a
series of seven suicide bombing blasts
killing Christians at a number of
churches there were also a blast at
other places including the hotel
government officials in the country have
already pointed to an Islamic terror
group called national foul eeeek Jo moth
I'm probably mispronouncing that but
that's the
a Islamic terror group in the country
that they're aware of and a bit on their
radar screen and so that's who they're
pointing to in the early stages here and
this is the reality for Christians okay
for many Christians outside of the US
and it's easy for us to get complacent
in this country to forget that our
Christian brothers and sisters have to
worry about these kinds of things when
they head out the door for church on
Sunday especially on a day like Easter
you know we don't we don't have to
really worry about this I mean it there
have been attacks in this country as
well including just last year but
generally speaking it's not the same as
it is in other parts of the world
especially as I said on these on these
high holy days you think about it was
just two years ago on Palm Sunday in
Egypt well over a hundred Christians
were killed in suicide bombings at
churches and now of course it's
happening on Easter what I want to
emphasize here first of all is that
while this is an enormous tragedy it is
not a unique occurrence okay
attacks on Christians especially by
Islamists have been an utterly routine
thing for a very long time the group the
group open doors has some statistics on
its website it says each month August
this is this is a these are statistics
monthly statistics each month on average
345 Christians are killed for their
faith
105 churches or other Christian
buildings are burned or attacked over
200 Christians are arrested and detained
without trial that's each month okay so
this as I said is a reality of life for
many Christians worldwide and and it's
important for us to recognize that
Christians are by far certainly among
the most persecuted group in the entire
world and so think about even this
should this should be something that is
a motivation to us first of all as
Christians in this country
not just to pray for our persecuted
brothers and sisters which we should be
doing and not just to lend our help in
our resources to them which we should
also be doing so we need to be doing to
those things those two things but the
third thing that we can do in response
to the persecution suffered by
Christians overseas is to stop being
such lazy cowards you know with it
that's another thing we could do I mean
think about how much of an effort it is
for us to just get ourselves to get up
and go to church on a Sunday you know
and we're looking for a million excuses
and you know you'd rather stay home
sleep in watch TV whatever meanwhile for
us going to church it's it's you know
it's a ten minute drive you go in it's
air conditioning maybe afterwards they
have some some you know food and drink
and then in the church basement or even
there might even be food and drink
during church depending on which church
you're going to these days and so it's
just it's all it's it's a perfectly
wonderful comfortable experience no risk
at all it takes a you know an hour of
your time you know maybe a little bit
more than that but still somehow it's
it's too much for a lot of us we don't
want to put that kind of effort into
into our faith and into communing
together as Christians well think about
overseas you know not only are they
going off into far less comfortable
churches that are a lot further away and
a lot of these country places like Sri
Lanka okay they're they're not going to
have ten churches on every block like we
do in some in some places in America so
you're going a lot further Church is
gonna be a lot less comfortable and most
pressingly of all you know that you live
in a hostile environment where there are
radical Muslim militants all around and
it's just a matter of time before your
church is targeted and yet they still go
even in spite of that well we just can't
be bothered so I think that's that's
something that we should be doing as
Christians that's one way that we should
be motivated to actually care about our
faith try to live according to it take
take part in it and expend maybe just a
little bit of effort in being Christian
that's that's one thing I take from it
another thing the fact that Christians
are targeted so often and on such a wide
scale that's what makes it all the more
important to actually acknowledge what's
happening and who the victims are and
that and that is why it's a problem when
prominent and influential people refuse
to do that okay so yesterday shortly
after the news broke of the attacks
several prominent Democrats release
their cans statements of remorse but
they all used a certain phrase that has
since gotten a lot of attention let me
pull up the so this is Barack Obama this
is what he tweeted yesterday he said the
attacks on tourists and Easter
worshipers in Sri Lanka are an attack on
humanity on a day devoted to love
Redemption and renewal we pray for the
victims and stand with the people of Sri
Lanka
here's Hillary Clinton on this holy
weekend for many faiths we must stand
united against hatred and violence I'm
praying for everyone affected by today's
horrific attacks on Easter worshippers
and travelers in Sri Lanka Julian Castro
on a day of redemption and hope the evil
of these attacks on Easter worshipers
and tourists and Sri Lanka is deeply
saddening my prayers today are with the
dead and injured and their families may
we find Grace and there were several
other tweets like that from Democrats
Easter worshipers the word Christian
doesn't appear in any of these
statements they are Easter worshippers
now if just one of them had used that
odd phrase not a phrase that you hear
often at all I don't think I've ever
heard anyone say that before Easter
worshippers but if just one of them had
to use that phrase then I would say okay
well it's a weird choice of words not
much else going on there the fact that
Obama and Clinton and Castro and several
other Democrat
all seized on this one phrase at roughly
the same time and phrasing phrased it
basically the same way that tells me
that this is calculated now this has
drawn some comparisons to Elan Ilhan
Omar's tweet about Notre Dame the Notre
Dame Cathedral fire as if you'll
remember last week she she she when that
happened she sent out a tweet talking
about the art and architecture but
didn't specifically call it a church or
discuss its spiritual significance and
she was getting a lot of criticism for
that now I defended Omar on that because
it was a perfectly normal and fine tweet
and as a Muslim I don't really expect
her to extol the spiritual virtues of a
church because she's a Muslim and and it
doesn't have any spiritual significance
to her so I thought that criticism was
stupid this is different though okay
because this seems very much like a
decision was made to avoid using the
word Christian and instead to adopt a
kind of bizarre euphemism now why do
that well because Christians are not an
approved victim group these people Obama
Clinton Castro etc they don't want us to
to to immediately associate Christian
with victim they want if anything the
opposite sort of Association they want
us to associate Christians with
terrorists and bullies but if Christians
are victims that throws a wrench in the
whole narrative and that's the reason
why they chose Easter worshippers
instead and I and I am 100% convinced
that that was a decision a calculated
decision that was made now of course we
all know when they say Easter worship we
know what they mean we know that people
who worship on Easter are Christians but
the idea is to blunt the emotional
visceral reaction you get from hearing
Christians were attacked they don't want
that reaction so the idea is to make it
sound as vague and ambiguous as possible
and yeah that's a problem if you don't
think it's a problem think about this
imagine think about after the the
Orlando attack at the at the gay
nightclub in Orlando back in the twenty
sixteen or fifteen well imagine if if
Obama had
called it an attack on bar hoppers or on
club attendees or something in that vein
and had made no mention that they were
gay people chosen as victims for that
fact well he wouldn't do that and he
didn't do that politicians especially on
the left but on the right as well made
sure to specifically mention the LGBT
community and and homophobia and so on
and at the very beginning they were they
were making it about that and for good
reason maybe a better analogy actually
would be just because it's more recent
would be the attacks at the at the
mosques in in New Zealand last month
here's what so there were two mosques
were attacked in those horrible attacks
and here's what Obama and Clinton said
after those attacks Obama said Michelle
and I send our condolences to the people
of New Zealand we grieve with you and
the Muslim community all of us must
stand against hatred in all its forms
Hillary my heart breaks for New Zealand
in the global Muslim community we must
continue the fight to fight the
perpetuation and normalization of
Islamophobia and racism in all its forms
white supremacist terrorists must be
condemned by leaders everywhere their
murderous hatred must be stopped
okay well that gives up the game right
there doesn't it there was obviously a
decision that was made to make sure to
mention Muslim and Islamophobia white
supremacism there were and there was
obviously a decision not to mention
specifics yesterday okay so you just you
can't compare I don't see how anyone can
compare Hillary's tweet about the church
attacks to her tweet about the mosque
attacks and not see a problem it's very
clear okay what she did not say what she
made a point of not saying is
this is an attack on Christians his law
you know Islamic terrorism must be
condemned everywhere it's a worldwide
scourge even though that's true she
didn't say I mean the very fact that the
term Islamophobia exists and khrysta
phobia doesn't really exist or though no
one really uses it
even though Christians are killed by
Muslims for their faith far far far more
than in Reverse that tells you
everything you need to know right there
it's all about narrative building and
that's in that's and that's all that
these Democrats care about in any given
situation and the whole idea of
victimhood is so valuable to them and so
precious that they they guard it and
they will not allow the wrong groups
into that camp they just won't allow it
and so even if there are hundreds of
Christians being killed every single
month for their faith across the world
and most of the time by Muslims they
just they can't they can't acknowledge
that they never will and that is
cowardly and disgusting and I mean it
would be hard to go overboard in
condemning it once you understand what
this is really coming from or what you
know what the real motivation is
meanwhile I think it would be
hypocritical not to mention this as well
since we're on the subject of bad tweets
on Easter here was Donald Trump's
Twitter message on Easter
he said East Happy Easter I've never
been happier or more content because
your country is doing so well with an
economy that is the talk of the world
and may be stronger than it has ever
been before
have a great day no mention of Jesus no
mention of Christianity his Easter
message is about himself and that's all
he said on the subject on Twitter
yesterday he spent the rest of the day
talking about themselves but the rest of
Easter I mean Easter Sunday's on he's
just ranting on Twitter about himself
and about Muller he did send one tweet
about the
attacks he also made no mention of
Christians in his tweet I didn't just
said people were attacked and originally
he said 138 million people were killed
and then that's a heck of a typo one bet
went back and changed it so I mean let's
just be real here guys I if Obama had
tweeted this exact thing on Easter
during his presidency he had tweeted out
an Easter message that was completely
about himself and his own successes and
make no mention at all of any of the
holidays actual meaning or significance
we would have lost our freaking minds
and we know it okay so I'm not losing my
mind over this I wouldn't have lost my
mind over that but I don't lose my mind
about tweets in general but it is
stupidness are narcissistic nonsense and
it shows yet again that Trump cannot
manage to care about anything that does
not directly relate to himself and I'm
not I'm not a fan of that I I don't
think that's a good thing and I think
it's a thing worthy of condemnation and
I'm not gonna let it slide just because
it's a Republican I know most people
will I'm not gonna do that this tweet
from a Democrat would send the right
into conniptions and you know it and I
know it everyone knows it I mean
everyone's right now it was an earshot
of me knows that I'm 100% right about
that right so I think it should it
therefore it provoked at least some kind
of reaction from us now like hey you
know why not I mean can you say
something about what the holiday
actually means you're supposedly a
Christian yourself so the hill the
Hillary and Obama tweets were cowardly
PC nonsense the Trump tweet is
narcissistic nonsense and that's what we
get cowardice and narcissism from our
ruling class that's all we can expect
from them as always wonderful okay
moving on
speaking of cowardice and nonsense and
everything else let's take a look at
this because I think it's interesting
that we can see kind of the anatomy of a
smear it can be grotesque to inspect but
but also instructive and in this case
the person being smeared is yours truly
so let's back up for a moment a few days
ago on the show during the email portion
of the of the of the show at the end I
answered a question from somebody who
wanted to know how I could support the
abolition of abortion while opposing gay
adoption now if that seems like kind of
a non sequitur to you as if okay this
those two issues aren't related well
you're right but I can tell you I get
this question a lot especially during
Q&A is that on college campuses it comes
up every single time without
exaggeration and the logic is that well
if we abolish abortion we're gonna end
up with a whole bunch of new babies in
the adoption system and then we're gonna
need gay couples to come in and adopt
some of these kids so that they don't
end up languish and languishing in the
system for years on end so as the logic
goes if you can call it that well you're
a hypocrite if you oppose gay adoption
while wanting to abolish abortion
because that means you're you'd be
consigning these kids to the adoption
system which even if that were true that
would still be preferable to killing
them okay it's still better it's better
to be in the adoption system than dead
so let's just be clear about that number
one but there are a lot of problems with
with the question and the the
assumptions behind it and I answered the
same question the same way that I always
do first I pointed out that it's a myth
that babies who go up for adoption could
stay in the system for years they don't
they won't it really doesn't happen it
can be hard to get an older child
adopted that's true but infants are
adopted easily because there's a waiting
list like 50 miles long of people who
are of families who are qualified
they've filled out all the paperwork
they paid the money and they're eager to
adopt an infant there's there's a very
very long waiting list of families in
that position and families will wait
four years for the opportunity to
opportunity to adopt an infant
it is it's more difficult to get and
that's so in this scenario where
abortion is made illegal and then
there's supposedly gonna be in this
influx of of children up for adoption
well those are gonna be babies right
it's not like abortion is abolished and
then that means everyone keeps their
kids for five years and then puts them
up for adoption so we're talking about
babies in the system and babies get
adopted the reason why unfortunately
sadly it can be harder to get older
children adopted is well there are a
number of reasons number one families a
lot of families that they want to adopt
an infant so they can form that bond
right away and of course with older
children sometimes you know you if you
have already have kids if you have
younger kids and you're worried about
there are just other concerns that come
into play that aren't really there for
for babies so that's the first thing
second point I pointed out that both
mother and father are indispensable a
child needs both so if we're talking
about two men adopting it seems that
we're saying that the mother is
expendable if we're talking about two
women - women adopting then it seems
that we're saying that the father is
expendable we're saying well you know
you don't really need that I think that
neither is expendable
and that's a biological fact it's got
nothing to do with with any moral
judgments about homosexuality or
whatever the point being you don't need
to even you don't need to be a Christian
you don't need to believe in you know
biblical sexual morality - see the point
here this is about biology that every
single child has a mother and father
naturally biologically and if their
mother if their biological parents are
unwilling or unable to care for them
then the most natural and and and and
and the healthiest thing is to find them
a new mother and father not two fathers
or two mothers or one mother or one
father well and as I said you know there
are kids who
obviously in this country end up in
different sorts of situations who don't
have a mother and father and I mean
there are all there are plenty of kids
who have just just a mother sometimes
kids who have just a father
single-parent homes those kids are not
it's not like they're doomed to be
failures in life and that their life is
going to be miserable not saying that
what I'm saying is that is a
disadvantage that they have to get over
and and overcome and succeed in spite of
which they can and and and so many of
them do thank God but if a kids in the
adoption system and we're trying to find
a situation for them don't we want to
find them the best possible situation to
give them the best possible chance well
one of the smear merchants over at Media
Matters picked up on this segment I
guess because they monitor this show so
hi guys by the way great great to have
you and they they summarized this this
guy Jason Campbell is a twitter handle
at Jason s Campbell CA MP bll he this is
how he summarized the point that I made
here's the tweet here I'll show to you
he says The Daily wires Matt Walsh would
rather have kids in orphanages than with
same-sex parents so that's his
characterization okay it's not a quote
that's his characterization of what I
said well the British publication called
the independent they got wind of this
and they did their own article article
and in their article for the headline
they used that tweet okay they used the
tweet of some guy giving a biased
paraphrase of what I said and they made
that the headline as if it was my quote
when it was that guys quote about what I
said so their headline in the in the in
the independent is us conservative says
he would rather a child remain in an
orphanage than be adopted by a gay
couple well here's the problem I didn't
say that okay you could try to infer
that you can assume that that's what I
meant
you can try to peer into my soul and
read my mind that's not what I said so
if you're gonna put it in the headline
that that you SQS conservative says X Y
Z well it seems to me
the thing that you say that I said I
should have actually said and I didn't
say that
that is what someone else said so here's
the here's a shot of the article by Greg
Evans and the in the independent and
then they quote me in the article
verbatim and their quote does not
support the headline here's what I said
verbatim according to their own article
I'll just read exactly what is it in my
mind every child needs and deserves a
mother and father and that's a
biological need there is a reason why
every person history has been created by
a mother and father so even if you don't
want to use the word God let's say
nature clearly intends for child to have
a mother and father which is why every
child does have a mother and father what
I would ask is what I would ask you is
if we're talking about gay adoption
which of the two is expendable mother or
father if we're talking about two gay
men adopting a child we can we we can
just get rid of the mother and say that
a guy could do that well a guy can't do
that a man cannot function as a mother a
man can be a very loving father but he
cannot be a mother that is a role that
he can biologically not fulfill and
there are certain emotional and
psychological needs that a child has
that if he does not have a mother at
home will not be met that doesn't mean
the child is doomed
and can't end up being happy and
fulfilled in life but he will be happy
and fulfilled in spite of that
disadvantage okay so that's that's what
they quote me as saying but that's not
what they put in the headline so the
headline should be us conservatives says
that mothers are indispensable that's
the headline right and that's ads it's a
headline that everyone should be able to
get behind but they do want to put that
in there because that doesn't make for a
good headline I guess and then they go
on to say in the article Walsh's radical
comments have been met with derision
online by people aghast at his views on
gay couples fostering children radical
what what's radical about that anyone
want to explain that to me Jason
Campbell such your since you've
apparently pulled the short straw you
have to watch my show what you want to
explain do you want to stop being a
misquoting coward and actually address
the point you snivelling conniving
coward you want to actually give it a
shot you want to use your brain
for 10 seconds explain to me explain to
me what's uh what's what's what's what's
radical about the idea that mother that
children need mothers do you disagree do
you disagree the children I'm saying
children need mothers mothers are great
mothers are indispensable okay it's the
kind of message you hear around Mother's
Day every year
well does that scandalize you when you
hear that Jason Campbell does it scanned
allows you to hear that that mothers are
indispensable and are great and children
need them do you disagree well explain
to me why I've just come out and say
that yeah I mean a man can do everything
a mother can do you don't really even
need mothers it left people a gap a
guest there a guest that someone said
children need mothers I am a guest at
this biological fact that cannot be
denied but this of course is how the
media operates I'm not surprised by it
but that doesn't make it any better
[Music]
it's just it's it's it's frustrating for
me because I enjoy having discussions
about these kinds of issues and so I
would love if somebody would step up to
the plate and provide some kind of
counterpoint because I would love to
hear what it is I can't even imagine
what it could be I mean how could you
simply argue against the basic idea that
the most ideal situation is for a child
to have a mother and father I mean I've
seen to me I've got everything on my
side including nature
I've got nature I've got you know all of
human history on my side I mean it seems
like I've I've got a lot going for me
here in making this point so I'm just
curious what the mothers are expendable
crowd would say I don't even know what
they would say because they don't bother
making any point all they do is just cry
and freak out did you hear what he said
oh my gosh I'm a guest I'm a guest at
this by the way that's how everyone at
Media Matters that's how I imagine them
that's how I imagine I'm saying
everything is with it just there they're
constantly in the process of fainting so
I'm waiting you know if anyone wants to
step up to the plate and offer a some
sort of rebuttal and I'd be fascinated
to hear all right let's jump ahead to
emails Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com this is from JP
says dear mr. Walsh eventual dictator of
America I am taking issue with something
you said on today's show you said that
McDonald's is the best fast-food
restaurant when in fact it is an
undeniable fact that chick-fil-a is the
greatest fast-food restaurant if your
dictatorship is one that holds
McDonald's above chick-fil-a I'm not
sure it's a dictatorship I want to live
in well JP I have good news with this
kind of insubordination you won't have
to worry about living under my
dictatorship I will take care of that
problem for you swiftly I assure you
though probably not painlessly this is
from Lisa says greetings Matt as a
Catholic do you believe that all the
suppose in real relics paraded by the
Catholic Church crown of thorns pieces
of the cross and nails from the cross at
cetera are actually real if not are you
a rare form of Catholic in this regard
seeing as many churches claim to have
certain relics that they couldn't all
possibly have how do you decide which
ones are actually real and which ones
aren't I could be wrong on this but my
understanding is that Protestants don't
think those relics are real to be clear
obviously we acknowledge that they
existed at one point just not that
they've necessarily been preserved and
are on display in churches today we'll
be curious to hear a Catholic
perspective on this thanks and love the
show hi Lisa uuuugh I don't really have
a blanket policy when it comes to relics
I think that some of them are probably
real and some probably aren't and it
depends
I'd have to look at the history of any
particular relic before I came to a
tentative conclusion about whether or
not I believe it's real but no I don't
just automatically believe that anything
is an ancient holy relic just because
someone says it is or because it's
enclosed in glass somewhere at a church
and it's not like we you know
we are you know we're not required to
affirm that and I and I I know you
didn't make that claim I just wanted to
clarify because it seems like there
really are a lot of non-catholics who
think that as Catholics we are required
to believe all of these random things
you know any claim that's made by any
church or any relic or any miracles I
was like we have to believe all that and
that's and that's simply not the case we
just like you we are able to use our own
judgment and decide if we believe these
things or not the most that the church
will do with a lot of this stuff
including especially miracle claims and
if someone claims a miracle then the
church will has a whole process of
looking into it and very very often
probably 99% of the time the church will
say no you know it doesn't appear to be
a miracle and then you got that 1% of
the time and in those in those cases
most of the time the most the church
will do is say that okay you know we've
looked into this and this is a miracle
worthy of belief you don't have to
believe it but we've looked into it and
seems to be a miracle but at the end of
the day you can form your own conclusion
so so that's kind of where I am with
with with relics here's an example this
isn't really I don't know if I'd call it
a relic per se but I was just talking to
my family about this yesterday at Easter
this claim because some people my family
just came back from from Italy and I was
asking them about this there's this
claim that I only recently heard about
that the Holy Family's house was
airlifted out of Nazareth by angels in
the 13th century and transported to
Italy where it stands today and and
people go and they visited a pope in the
12 hundreds announced basically that the
Holy Family's house had appeared there
in Italy as a miracle angels had brought
it so I was asking some people my family
about this we got into a debate about it
do I believe that that angels
transported a house to Nazareth no I
don't I really don't believe that I
think it's kind of silly to be honest
I don't think there's any evidence any
reason to believe it there should be
evidence for something like for instance
there should be if this house existed in
the Middle East for for 1,200 years then
people should have known about it and
then one day they should have shown up
to pay their respects at the Holy
Family's house and look at that it's
gone right but I'm not aware of anything
like that it's just this house just
appeared one day and in Italy and
someone said it was only famous out so
that I don't believe that but do I
believe
for instance that Notre Dame had pieces
of the crown of thorns yeah I'm sure I
do I can't know for sure but I think
there is a history that you can trace
and with a lot of these relics not all
of them but with a lot of them you can
trace the history pretty far back you
know you could look at a documented
history that goes back to the early
centuries of the church and sometimes
even more and can it get even closer to
Christ than that and when you've got
something like that then I think it's
worthy of belief and I certainly
wouldn't go the opposite to the opposite
extreme and just dismiss all of that out
of hand because it makes sense right
that why wouldn't God have left us some
relics some keepsakes if you will for us
to just have and cherish all right let's
see this is from Connor says hey Matt
Passover got me thinking night and I
think I managed to map out how
reparations for slavery will work and I
wanted to get your opinion on it step 1
those with Egyptian heritage will pay
all the Jews and Christians for starters
step 2 the Jews and Christians will then
use that previously gotten money to pay
those with African heritage only if
they're white of course
step 2 a Muslims will start paying each
other for enslaving each other in the
past step 3 those with African heritage
will use their previously gotten money
from step 2 to pay each other similarly
to how it worked in step 2 a for past
Africans enslaving each other Native
Americans will pay each other two I
guess they will work it out among
themselves step for Chinese pay the
Turks the Portuguese will pay the
Japanese club a chart will pay your
staff was a good one thank you for all
you do from Connor Connor I find your
proposal totally acceptable and I say
let's let's do it I think the goal here
has to be that we all end up with
exactly the same amount of money it
started with we'll just pass all the
money around and then we'll end up in
the end where we started to begin with
this is from Garrett says hey Matt
yesterday I had the best conversation
I've ever had at a bar me and two other
young people had a deep discussion
regarding Christianity and philosophy we
mostly disagreed but agreed on a few
things and we're incredibly cordial with
each other before this I had been rather
negative about the state of such
fundamental debates in our society
though after this I am optimistic do you
believe young people are talking about
these things enough or is the education
system failing in that respect well
first of all Garrett you've stumbled on
a fundamental truth which is that the
best philosophical and theological
debates happen in dimly-lit bars over a
pint and I firmly believe that I I do
think that interesting and in-depth and
edifying debates and discussions between
people are are very possible in our
society especially at a bar but not only
at a bar but I think you need a couple
of ingredients besides beer number one
the people who are conversing with each
other needs actually respect each other
as people because if you hate each other
there's no hope for a dialogue right so
if you're if you're sitting down for a
beer with someone that means that you
respect them because you wouldn't if you
did that's the first thing you need
second thing is you need to have some
basic shared frame of reference you need
some underlying principle that everyone
agrees on something that you can appeal
to in the conversation because without
that it can't go anywhere and that I
think is why a lot of our conversations
don't go anywhere in this country so in
other words I can have a fun
conversation about football with any
knowledgeable football fan even if they
you know are a bad fan who likes a Bad's
bad horrible team like the Steelers or
the Jets
now I think that there's something
mentally wrong with Steelers and Jets
fans I think that maybe the arguably
they're all sociopaths and cannibals and
worse but we can at least talk we can
have a fun conversation even in spite of
that because we have that underlying
agreement that football is interesting
and we'd like to talk about but the
conversation wouldn't go anywhere if we
couldn't even agree on the basic
definition of what football is like if
I'm talking about football and and he's
talking about ping pong well that's not
gonna be a very interesting discussion
and it's the same with deeper subject we
have to agree on something you have to
have some kind of agreement somewhere we
can disagree on a million things and we
can argue about those things
and we can have an enjoyable argument
but there have to be a few basic
starting points that we share and the
problem in our society even apart from
the education system or anything else
the problem is very often you've got two
people or two groups that are arguing
with each other and they have no shared
starting point they have no frame of
reference they have no shared values no
shared priorities their fundamental
concept of reality is completely
opposite from each other and so it's
like it's like you're speaking different
languages and I think that's our our
problem all right but I'm glad that you
had that conversation and I've had many
of those myself and they are very
enjoyable this is from David says hi
Matt you talk a lot about space aliens
and similar subjects that's true my
feeling though is an is is that
exploring space is an enormous waste of
money when there's so much on earth that
needs fixing how do you respond to that
can we justify dumping billions into
space for no reason just seems silly to
me you know I don't see anything silly
about exploration and I hear this a lot
I think it satisfies an essential human
need okay it's it's part of what makes
us human this reminds me of the
conversation we had about Beauty you
know after the Notre Dame thing and I
was trying to make the point that yeah
beauty is not practical but it's it's
more than practical it's deeper than
that it's more transcend
right there are needs there are needs
that we have there are practical needs
that we have that put us in the same
camp as like squirrels and ants and
trees and so on you know we need water
and we need oxygen physical needs but
then there are needs that we have that
set us apart from all other known
creatures the hunger for beauty and for
transcendence that's what sets us apart
from those other creatures and so we
shouldn't stifle those desires we should
follow them even if it's impractical
even if it's expensive even if it's
risky it's how we become really human
really ourselves and I think the drive
for discovery is like this I think if we
if we were to stop discovering if we
were to stop surging ahead if we were
stopped to stop seeking new frontiers I
think we'd stop being we would stop
essentially being a human civilization
we'd be just like some kind of ant
colony right obsessed with its own
practical needs its own basic survival
and nothing more and who wants that who
wants to be like that I don't so what do
we gain from going into space well I
could actually point to a whole bunch of
practical things that have come from
space exploration a lot of everyday
items that started with astronauts and
with the space program but aside from
that we gain knowledge we gain expanded
horizons we gain hope we gain something
to look forward to something to dream
about I mean we gain more of what makes
human existence worthwhile
so we gain quite a bit I would say is it
worth the money then then yeah I believe
it is it really is I think we need
there's a modern tendency to see
everything in is a tendency shared even
by by Christians a tendency to see
everything in materialistic terms
everything in practical utilitarian
terms like what's you know what is this
doing for me immediately how is it
helping my bottom line like that that's
the question we all ask about almost
everything but there are things that are
bigger than that I mean music who needs
music right what do you need music floor
doesn't do anything for you it's not
gonna it doesn't doesn't pay the bills
most of us unless you're a professional
musician you can't eat it you can't
drink it but it makes life it's another
thing that part of what makes life worth
living it's part of what makes us human
all right um so we'll leave it there
thanks everybody for watching thanks for
listening
Godspeed today on the Ben Shapiro show
devastating bombings by radical
Islamists kill hundreds on Easter in Sri
Lanka fallout from the mullah report
continues and Elizabeth Warren makes a
radical proposal that's today on the Ben
Shapiro show